Aww yeah! Let’s learn English with Disney and Pixar’s hit animated film, Big Hero 6!
But before we start, every week we release lessons to
help intermediate and advanced learners like you
to improve their English in a fun and dynamic way.
If you’re new here, make sure you join our community of
over five million learners by subscribing now!
Let’s put it to practice! On a scale from 1 to 10,
how would you rate how helpful our channel is for improving your English listening?
Let us know in the comments down below!
By the way, most learners say that one of their biggest challenges is learning and remembering enough different words to communicate confidently!
Has that ever frustrated you?
Well in our Fluent with Friends course, you will learn some of the most
common words and expressions that natives actually use every day.
You will also learn how natives reduce, cut and connect the sounds, which is the secret to understanding us no matter how fast we speak.
If you’re tired of boring and traditional methods that
don’t make you fluent, you will love this course!
You can start learning today with our FREE 3-part masterclass. Just click up here or down in the description below to sign up now!
Many learners overuse common words they learned in school. A perfect example is saying “Hello”.
This is pretty boring, and honestly, we natives don’t use it so often.
In this lesson, Andrea will teach you 23 more fun ways to say “Hello” that natives actually use. Let’s check out a clip!